[Musik]
ja meine damen und herren normalerweise
würde ich jetzt mit den fünf chefs der
internationalen organisationen des iwf
der weltbank der wto der eu und der oecd
vor ihnen stehen und wir werden in einem
anderen saal aber die zeiten sind nicht
so wir hatten eine video-konferenz und
haben uns sozusagen zum zwölften mal
ausgetauscht die man diesmal ganz im
zeichen der pandemie
denn cupid 19 ist natürlich das
beherrschende thema für alle auf der
welt und so auch für die internationalen
organisationen
es war nicht verwunderlich dass alle
darauf hingewiesen haben dass wir in
einer tiefen globalen rezession sind und
genauso aber dafür geworben haben
möglichst schnell wieder auf einen
nachhaltigen entwicklungspfad
zurückzukommen und wir waren alle
überzeugt dass da für gemeinsames
handeln abgestimmtes handeln und nicht
unilaterales handeln die richtige
antwort ist und deshalb war klar der
multilateralismus stand schon vor der
pandemie vor einer großen
herausforderung und diese
herausforderung ist nicht kleiner
geworden
ich möchte vier bereiche aus unserem
gespräch aufgreifen wir waren uns alle
einig dass diese pandemie natürlich nur
beendet ist wenn es einen impfstoff gibt
beziehungsweise eine sehr gute
medizinische behandlungsmöglichkeit so
lange müssen wir mit dem virus leben und
deshalb ist es auch sehr wichtig einen
solchen impfstoff oder auch medikamente
als gemeinschaftliche globale güter zu
verstehen
das heißt sie müssen allen zur verfügung
gestellt werden und sie wissen dass
deutschland und andere ja schon dafür
auch auf einer geberkonferenz anfang mai
ihren beitrag geleistet haben
zweitens wir haben gesehen wie
schädliches ist wenn
wertschöpfungsketten zusammenbrechen und
deshalb ist die stärkung des
internationalen handels
systems von großer bedeutung das heißt
nicht dass wir nicht vielleicht in
einigen bereichen mehr diversifizieren
müssen aber die antwort auf die pandemie
kann mit sicherheit nicht sein alle
internationalen lieferketten jetzt zur e
nationalisieren dann würden alle einen
sehr hohen preis zahlen
und deshalb muss man mit sorge auch die
protektionistischen tendenzen sehen der
welthandels chef roberto also weder hat
noch mal darauf hingewiesen wie viele
unilaterale maßnahmen ist jetzt schon
wieder gibt eine besorgniserregende zum
beispiel auch dass es eine ganze reihe
von exportbeschränkungen im
lebensmittelbereich gibt und wir wissen
natürlich dass darauf hat auch die
welternährungsorganisation schon
hingewiesen dass aus der
arbeitslosigkeit aus der darauf
folgenden armut dann sehr schnell auch
hunger werden kann und deshalb ist
gerade die versorgung der menschheit mit
lebensmitteln in den nächsten monaten
von ganz besonderer bedeutung wir haben
dann gesprochen über die frage wie
können wir denn den wirtschaftlichen
erholungsprozess gestalten
es ist heute noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen worden dass insgesamt neun
billionen dollar in stützungsmaßnahmen
schon gegangen sind sowohl als zuschüsse
als auch als kredite wir haben ja in der
europäischen union auch schon fast die
zwei millionen euro grenze erreicht also
durchaus zwei millionen dollar dazu
beigetragen zu diesem neuen millionen
und das sind wichtige maßnahme ist auch
noch mal betont worden dass das von ganz
großer notwendigkeit ist und es ist auch
darauf hingewiesen worden dass die phase
der erholung auch noch einmal begleitet
werden muss durch konjunkturprogramme
die bundesregierung plant ja so etwas
auch und nicht etwa durch höhere steuern
dann dazu beigetragen wird dass man den
aufschwung wieder
ein schränkt beschränkt oder sogar zum
stillstand bringt das war ein wichtiges
anliegen wir müssen also auch die
erholungsphase mit erleichterungen für
das wirtschaften und damit auch für die
schaffung von arbeitsplätzen verbinden
im zusammenhang mit dem wirtschaftlichen
erholungsprozess ist natürlich noch
einmal darauf hingewiesen wurden von der
internationalen arbeitsorganisation von
guy ryder dass es von großer wichtigkeit
ist vor allen dingen eben auch in den
entwicklungsländern wieder arbeitsplätze
zu schaffen
die arbeitslosigkeit dort ist dramatisch
wenn das konsumverhalten in den
hochentwickelten ländern sich
einschränkt dann hat das natürlich für
die entwicklungsländer
dramatische auswirkungen und deshalb
wird die armutsbekämpfung in den
nächsten jahren sicherlich ein
wesentlicher punkt sein und wenn wir
einmal sehen 9 billionen dollar jetzt in
stützungsmaßnahmen das ist nicht gleich
verteilt über die welt sondern das sind
vor allen dingen die industrieländer die
das schaffen können zum teil vielleicht
auch die aufsteigenden länder unter den
brics ländern aber viele können das eben
nicht und deshalb ist der vierte punkt
von so großer bedeutung dass wir die
finanzierungserfordernisse gerade der
schwächeren staaten im auge haben müssen
das heißt für deutschland keine
entwicklungshilfe kürzen sondern weiter
investieren das heißt in in die
entwicklungshilfe
das heißt umschichten und auch hier so
wie unsere entwicklungshilfe minister
das macht gerade die mittel so einsetzen
dass sie jetzt auch auf diese ko wie
passen und das heißt dass wir einen
richtigen schritt gemacht haben das
schuldenmoratorium der g20 und des
pariser clubs das ist aber ja nur ein
moratorium das die schulden nicht
bedient werden müssen und es ist heute
im gespräch durchaus darauf hingewiesen
worden dass das vielleicht noch nicht
der letzte schritt ist sondern dass
gerade was die schuldentragfähigkeit
anbelangt weitere schritte folgen müssen
in dem zusammenhang der
entwicklungshilfe finanzierung haben wir
auch noch mal über den compact mit
afrika gesprochen
das ist jetzt ja sehr stark auch in die
verantwortlichkeit der weltbank
übergegangen die weltbank hat hier noch
einmal darauf hingewiesen wie wichtig es
ist länder afrikas zu ermutigen eine
bessere regierungsführung mehr
transparenz zu zeigen und damit dann
auch die finanzierung im bereich der
entwicklung besser möglich zu machen
genau das ist ja auch die philosophie
des compact mit afrika und wir werden
uns von deutscher seite hier natürlich
auch weiter intensiv einbringen
das war's im großen ganzen von unserer
video konferenz was ich ihnen berichten
wollte und jetzt hätten wir gelegenheit
für wenige frauen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben schon bei
der pressekonferenz mit herrn marc rom
gesagt krisenzeiten seinen zeiten um
auch zu kämpfen für eine idee ihre idee
haben sie vorhin angesprochen als
insider ganz am anfang werden
multilateralismus
haben sie da noch sehen sie da noch
genug mitstreiter und nachdem hertrampf
heute gesagt hat er könnte sich
vorstellen auch ein physisches
g7-treffen in camp david auszurichten im
juni würden sie bei einer einladung
dorthin fahren um für multilaterale ist
multilateralismus zu kämpfen
in welcher form auch immer das
g7-treffen stattfindet ich werde ob als
video konferenz oder anders ich werde
auf jeden fall für den multilateralismus
kämpfen das ist ganz klar
sowohl bei g 7 als auch bei g20
ja frank hier bei uns ab so motiviert
realismus wo bin ich auch interessieren
sie haben ja habe auch die
internationale koordination angesprochen
hatten sie denn seit montag gelegenheit
mit kanzler kurz sogar premierminister
ritte über einen kompromiss zu dem
recovery plan zu sprechen der ja
bilateral zwischen deutschland und
frankreich ausgearbeitet wurde und ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich
verstanden habe ob sie auch hinfahren
würden zum g7 wenn sie dann einmal an
kriegen ob sie jetzt also ich weiß nicht
ob sie sicher sind oder nicht ich wollte
das sagen was ich gesagt habe und dass
weitere warten wir einfach mal ab ich
habe meine worte mit bedacht gewählt so
und die andere frage war ich habe mit
den beiden kollegen noch nicht
gesprochen das wird sicherlich aber noch
geschehen wir sind jetzt in der phase wo
er wir erst mal auf den vorschlag der
kommission waren das ist ja dann der
entscheidende vorschlag auf dessen
grundlage wie auch arbeiten werden
deutschland und frankreich wollten
sozusagen diesen prozess begleiten und
auch konstruktiv begleiten aber das
nächste was jetzt passiert wird am 27
mai dann sein dass die kommission ihren
vorschlag vorlegt der wird dann der
gegenstand der diskussion mit allen
anderen mitgliedstaaten seien
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben auf die
rettungspakete hingewiesen mit den neuen
milliarden jetzt gibt es einen ganz
konkreten fall in deutschland die
lufthansa können sie bestätigen dass sie
sich geeinigt haben mit ihren
kabinettskollegen auf eine beteiligung
von 25,1 prozent und es gibt ja im
zusammenhang mit diesen rettungspaketen
die warnung dass die usa und china
besser aus der krise kommen könnten als
europäische und deutsche firmen teilen
sie die sorge etwa vom siemens chef also
ich glaube wir haben ja auch sehr
beherzt
unsere rettungsaktion geplant und führen
sie auch so durch sodass ich glaube dass
wir unseren unternehmen genauso eine
chance geben wollen wie das andere
länder auf der welt auch tun
zur lufthansa selbst kann ich ihnen
folgendes sagen die bundesregierung ist
in intensiven gesprächen mit dem
unternehmen und der eu kommission
es ist in kürze mit einer entscheidung
zu rechnen aber zu laufenden gesprächen
kann ich keine details berichten das
werden sie verstehen und ich würde auch
den rat ausgeben warten sie das ende der
gespräche ab es ist in kürze mit einer
entscheidung zu rechnen aber sie muss
dann auch fertig sein
dankeschön